amiel côté premier vice président de
l'uem qc l'union des municipalités du
québec est aussi maire de gaspé est avec
nous en direct elles danielle côté merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait un le québec et a donc
commencé son déconfinement il ya
maintenant une semaine
quel premier bilan même s'il est encore
tôt c'est vrai vous pouvez déjà tiré en
fait j'ai pu très ou du zinc est à peu
près 3 québec présentement le québec des
centres de personnes âgées les québec de
montréal il ya le québec de toutes les
régions du grand québec donc dans les x
lolë problématique est inquiétant
toujours c'est dans les foyers de
personnes aînées les propos des
personnes âgées particulièrement dans
les secteurs plus urbanisées du québec
la situation montréal demeure
préoccupant dans les régions du québec
depuis qu'on a entrepris les
confinements progressif
ça se passe quand même très bien
présentement donc malgré le
déconfinement n'y a pas eu de nouvelle
éclosion dans les régions du québec mais
le code de montréal est vraiment le
corps exceptionnelle qui est carrément à
part des restos du coeur alors qu'elle
et vous tu roules quel est le rôle des
maires dans cette nouvelle phase
en fait le rôle le rôle des maires c'est
un peu d appliquer sur le terrain ce qui
est recommandé par la santé publique du
québec ici au québec c'est la direction
de la santé publique qui dirige à peu
près tout ce qui se passe durant la
période de la parade et me donc c'est
lui qui ont les spécialistes qui peuvent
désigner quels sont les distances
sociales à respecter entre les personnes
est ce qu'on peut avoir écouté ou telle
autre type de rassemblement est-ce qu'on
peut mourir tel ou tel type de commerce
bfc la santé publique du québec qui gère
tout ça nous on est certains roulent de
plus si on veut passer le porte-voix
comme maire on se fait le porte-voix de
ce que les citoyens dignes comme
préoccupation comme comme désire
également dont comporte s'avère la santé
publique du québec est de notre côté on
applique sur le terrain les normes
recommandées par la santé publique alors
vous évoquez les préoccupations
il y à des experts dont le docteur isaac
beaucop qu'il est spécialiste des
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital de ton
bretons il estime que ceux des
confinement et bien il se fait trop tôt
trop vite est ce que c'est un point de
vue partagé par certains maires je
voudrais en partie ya certaines mères
qui ont effectivement cette crainte de
voir le déconfinement se faire trop
rapidement
personnellement je suis davantage portés
à me baser ou à me fier sur ce que la
direction de la santé publique du québec
nous apporte
je voudrais là où le déconfinement et de
faire un peu plus mal c'est que les gens
avaient beaucoup de craintes et certains
et certaines mères dans certaines
régions du québec y avait des craintes
de voir par exemple la population du
secteur névralgique au québec le secteur
du grand montréal se déplacer vers les
régions du québec et apporter avec eux
le virus cependant c'est ce que cette
can répondait à ce que les montréalais
vont voyager davantage aux régions du
québec présentement je ne crois pas donc
il ya une forme de crin qui est humaine
je crois ce qu'on vient de vivre un
confinement massif en réouvrant les
frontières vers les régions du québec
c'est certain que ça peut apporter son
lot de craintes je le comprends mais
vous dire que c'est une crème que je
partage je voudrais de façon minime mais
je ne partage pas ce créateur de façon
énorme je portais vraiment faire
confiance aux experts en santé publique
du québec
il ya des confirmands cette façon
progresser vous le voyez quand chaque
fois que le gouvernement ou la santé
publique faire un pas dans un sens c'est
le réalise qu'ils vont trouver c'est le
réalisme qui sont commis une erreur
ils ont l'humilité requises pour faire
un pas de recul réajuster la situation
et suivre la progression des maladies du
coup finalement dans ce déconfinement ce
que vous dites c'est qu'il ya eu une
unité entre les différentes autorités du
québec pour que cette phase se passe au
mieux
effectivement donc ici au québec
en fait vous savez on est sur le système
fédéral canadien comprenant le
gouvernement fédéral canadien le
gouvernement provincial du québec et les
gouvernements municipaux donc les villes
et les municipalités du québec
donc sur le terrain et les municipalités
notre rôle c'est d'appliquer les
recommandations sur les éléments qui
sont de la jurée de de la juridiction de
la compétence municipale
par exemple les aires de jeux pour
enfants les quatre jours pour les
enfants également les provenances des
pistes cyclables chez des rats sa valeur
du municipal mais au provincial
c'est le provincial qui dirige son re la
façon dont doit évoluer la pandémie
c'est le provincial avec la santé
publique qui prennent les décisions de
caisse qui commandera des conflits ni
comment de voir qu'on finit par exemple
et au fédéral on va poser les mesures
par exemple sur l'international où des
mesures large et où des mesures par
exemple pourra aider miniser la
population donc chacun a son rôle et
tout le monde se coordonnent et ça donne
un résultat qui a kick et parfois que
certains alors il ya aussi un certain
décision de repousser d'une semaine la
réouverture des commerces est ce que
c'était la décision la plus raisonnable
comment est-ce qu'elle a été reçu
notamment par les petits commerçants on
est des plus petites communes
je voudrais que les commerçants voudrait
la plupart la plupart voudrait ouvrir
rapidement à cette question économique
l'on parle de sous à ce moment là on
parle de leur gangue pêche
donc c'est normal que les commerçants
veulent redorer rapidement là au delà de
l'économie il ya la santé donc et on
doit on doit d'abord et avant tout se
fixe basé sur l'expertisé en santé
publique car la santé publique bien 10
rebonds ont ré ouvre tel pan de
l'économie on trouve l'hôtel porte
d'économie on s'ajustera après lancé que
si la santé nul et que je jouais plus
primordial pour préserver la santé des
citoyens de retarder certaines
ouvertures de retarder les ouvertures de
classes de retarder des ouvertures de
commerces et c'est très bien comme ça
nous comme maire notre rôle c'est donne
un peu de partager l'expertisé de la
santé publique
donc je ne juge pas outillés pour des
galas santé publique ne mène pas la
guerre de la bonne manière
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que à
notre humble avis ils prennent des
décisions raisonnables dans les
circonstances et on sait que ça fait des
heureux on sait que ça fait des
malheureux présentement mais c'est ça
peut partir de cette guerre merci
beaucoup daniel côté d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
premier vice président de l'union des
municipalités
du québec mais également maire de gaspé